le lièvre et la tortue conte créole
réunionnais traduction et adaptation
d'yvette duchemann aux éditions sourya
qu'on perd lièvre et qu'on perd tortue
se promènent et discutent dans un grand
jardin qu'on perd tortue est perplexe il
dit à son camarade je ne comprends pas
tous les joueurs je sors je vais
chercher du travail ici sur la terre
mais je n'en trouve pas il n'y a plus
rien mais que faut-il donc vers son ami
le liège lui répond aussitôt
moi j'ai une idée c'est simple il faut
aller voir le bon dieu et chercher du
travail là haut dans le ciel combertault
tu as pièce immédiatement allons lamy on
monte mais comme mathieu faire toi qu'il
long silence tellement l'on dit le
lièvre en riant les deux compères se
mettent d'accord et décident de voyager
le lendemain le lendemain matin compères
tortue se prépare de très bonne heure
quand il est prêt il se glisse dans la
bertel de son camarade yeves qui ne le
voient pas ce dernier s'est réveillé de
bonne heure il endossa baird tel et
montent jusqu'au ciel
dès qu'ils arrivent au ciel ils pensent
à bethel par terme
copé à lièpvre n'en croit pas ses yeux
quelle surprise qui va t'il devant lui
mais comment tu fais pour arriver ici
devant moi toi qui lancent ils en
tellement lent oui oui bien sûr je mange
longtemps mais je mange depuis hier soir
je n'ai pas dormi moi répond qu'on perd
tortue encore et bail qu'on paie aliev
propose à son ami de commencer à
travailler et tous les deux travaillent
pendant toute la journée le soir venu
qu'on paie aliev se glisse à nouveau
dans la baie at-elle de son compagnon
pour redescendre sur la terre qu'on paie
aliev se frotte les yeux mais ce n'est
pas possible tu arrives sur la terre
avant mais ce n'est pas possible mais
comment fais tu dois qu'ils ont si dans
tellement l'on perde on tue qui a plus
d'une parole dans son sac répond
tranquillement mais c'est simple je
descends faisandé connu deux mois vont
s'écouler ainsi tous les jours qu'on
perd tortue monte et descend dans la
berthe elles deux compères lièvre
cependant un match qu'on payait voit son
ami entrée subrepticement dans saab
airtel et ne dit rien et l'emmène au
travail le soir venu compères liev anuza
compétentes eu dalons tu sais je voulais
te dire je vais brûler ma bertel mais
comment ça mais pourquoi mais attend
moins d'être aubin mais enfin quel
mousse te pique mais un e 2 comprend pas
dit qu'on perd tortue complètement abbas
oti compères liev à déterminer il prend
des feuilles sèches
quelques branches il en fut un feu il y
jette sa bertel
nos jetons prix ne fait pas ça tu as
besoin de cette bête elle attend est
d'être en bas qu'on perd trop tu cries
essaie en vain d'enlever la bertel du
feu il pleure il est désespéré il
regarde la bertel qui se consume
lentement très lentement mais j'ai peur
pourquoi pleures tu ainsi que
t'arrive-t-il compères tortue demande
qu'on dernière n'en sais rien c'est
cette fumée elle me brûle les yeux
ti compères tortue pendant que la perte
elle se consume totalement qu'on perd
lièvre quant à lui se prépare pour
descendre sur la terre qu'on perd
tortues ne le suis pas
vas-y ne m'attend pas je descends dans
un moment qu'on paie un lièvre descend
sur la terre resté seul compères tortue
réfléchi il connaît les arbres il grimpe
à mao et rapidement très rapidement il
confectionne une corde avec les corses
de l'arbre une fois celle ci terminée
ils attachent un tronc d'arbre il
commence à redescendre sur la terre
malheureusement la corde est trop courte
et compères dont tu sud dans
l'arrière-cour deux compères liège tant
bien que mal qu'on perd tortue se remet
de son choc
il entend compères liège qui crie mais
qui l'énervent humaine qui lancent des
cailloux sur ma maison c'est moi copé à
lierse et moi je suis tombé répond qu'on
perd tortue compères lièvre sort de chez
lui et vient à la rencontre deux
compères tortueux mais que t'arrive-t-il
compères tortue tout penaud lui répond
tu savais bien que je montais que je
descendais chaque joie dans ta bertel
comment je vais faire maintenant je
suis lent s'ils ont tellement lent
comment vais-je faire maintenant que tu
l'a brûlée j'ai failli me tue avec cette
côte au kwat compères liev le regarde et
lui dit gravement
c'est vrai que tu es mon ami cependant
tu dois comprendre que dans la vie il
faut prendre son courage à deux mains
au lieu de compter sur les autres je te
laisse y réfléchir